SOPHIE CLYDE: Hi.
I'm Sophie.
PABLO VILLALOBOS: I'm Pablo.
SOPHIE CLYDE: And this is
our project, Night Hunter.
So our early concept
for this game
was something like an invisible
maze that you could only hear.
So we had the idea
of trying to--
the original idea came from
the idea of superheroes
who have enhanced senses.
Since this was to be an
audio-only game, we thought,
how can we enhance your hearing?
We thought, what if you
could hear the things
that you can't see?
So the idea was that you would
try to move through a maze.
You would hear what--
you would use something
like sonar to try to--
you'd send out a wave.
It would make a sound.
You could tell where it
was in space and avoid it.
That's pretty hard,
as it turns out.
One of the things we wanted
to explore by making this game
was how good at people--
or how good are people
at actually figuring out
where that invisible thing is.
It turns out the answer
is not very good.
If you're trying
to avoid something,
that's very important that
you are very good because you
can't tell where the edges are.
You can just tell it's
vaguely over there.
PABLO VILLALOBOS: Our original--
when we did original play
storming, playing around with
physical objects to come up
with a concept, our
original concept--
we split two tables
up and we put objects
down to represent sound sources.
And we had people
walk through it.
And when they got close to the
sound source, we would ping.
And that was our original
ideating playtest.
But after that, we
transitioned into more
of a collection kind
of game because it's
hard to detect those edges.
And so with our first
physical playtest,
we had one player
wearing blackout glasses.
So they were,
effectively, blind.
And then a bunch of our
playtesting helpers,
who are in this room,
would act as sound sources
that the player is
trying to collect.
And so they would move
opposite the direction
where the player is facing.
So it's as though they're
always moving forward relative
to all the other people.
And all the sound sources would
each take a step in cadence
and then make some
sort of sound.
We did clapping at first.
But we had a lot of, actually,
very important findings
just from this first playtest.
SOPHIE CLYDE: Yeah.
One of the things
we found out is
that if everyone is making the
same sound at the same time,
it's really, really
hard to figure out
where they're coming from.
It's just one big cloud of
"what the heck is going on?"
And it was also pretty
hard to try to even--
we had to show people
how to move at first.
It was hard to understand
just from a description.
If he's looking at me,
I'm going this way.
And we had to have
someone pointing which
way the person was looking.
So we tried a
second round, where
the-- where everyone was
making a different noise,
and they weren't moving in sync.
And it proved really helpful
for our playtester, who
could lock onto one
sound, turn toward it
until they got close enough.
When the person got close
enough, tapped on the shoulder,
they were out--
collected, basically.
And they got slowly
faster and faster just
locking onto that one individual
sound, pointing towards it,
collecting it until
they were all out.
We had a timer for
that second round.
The timer was not necessary.
So we're like, well, yay!
This works so much better.
So we moved on to making
a unity prototype.
PABLO VILLALOBOS: So our
original unity prototype
was kind of like this.
It was a duplication of
this, where the frames were
in the center of the screen.
And then there was a cloud
of sound sources around them.
And they would move against
where the player was looking.
So again, it was like they
were flying around and trying
to collect these sound sources.
But we quickly found
out that it was--
like the other
team mentioned-- is
that it's very hard to determine
or to lock onto something when
you can-- when there's
variance on the z-axis
when you can look up and down.
So we flattened it.
So they were all around you.
But even then, it was
still hard, pretty hard,
to focus on each
individual sound.
SOPHIE CLYDE: So we decided
to change to an endless runner
prototype, where the
idea is that you're here.
Things are constantly
coming at you,
and you have to
turn your head so
that they will move toward you.
It's like there's
something coming over here.
Oh, I can hear that.
Oh, now it's coming
at me-- collected.
Huzzah.
PABLO VILLALOBOS:
So we transitioned
to a linear experience.
SOPHIE CLYDE: So our final
product is Night Hunter.
The idea is that--
it's a little hard to see
in this particular photo.
But you're this tiny,
little arrow ship thing.
And there are
small sound sources
that you can hear they're
headed toward you.
And you have to turn your
head, wearing the frames,
to find them.
They will-- if you
are looking at it,
it will move towards you.
If you miss it, it hits a
invisible plane behind you
and is deleted, and
another one spawns
because another thing we found
was if there are multiple,
you will hear one over
here and one over here,
and you can't tell
which is which.
Even if the sounds
are different,
it's still really hard.
It's easier if the
sounds are different.
It's still really hard.
PABLO VILLALOBOS: And another
massive change which--
we made is that
there is a UI now.
So before, we were just
doing completely blind--
you're just--
you're only using
your ears to play.
But we actually made this UI
for playtesting initially--
or for debugging so that we
could see the sounds coming
at the player.
But we thought maybe
for a tutorial,
this would be really useful
because then the player
could conceptualize what they're
doing before they go blind.
But we decided to actually
add it into the game.
So you can always see where
you are, and you can see
the sounds coming into view.
They start out of you.
So you still have to use
your ears to localize it.
But once you get close
enough to it, you can see it.
And then with more precision,
you can actually collect it.
SOPHIE CLYDE: Instead of
having a full range of vision
and sight, it's more like
you have a really, really
limited range of vision.
It's like being almost
blind because this is--
you still have to get yourself
in the general area using
your auditory senses.
And then you can see it.
And then that helps
with the final--
oh, it's right here.
I thought it was here-ish.
Oh, I can turn it.
I can see it now.
It's there.
PABLO VILLALOBOS: And with
this version of the game,
we felt like now it was--
we didn't want players to rely
too much on their visuals.
We still wanted to get that
audio-first gaming experience.
So what we decided to do is
have the screen occasionally
go black.
So you can't see anything.
And then you have to truly
rely on just your ears
to actually collect the sounds.
SOPHIE CLYDE: So you'll
be playing for a while.
And suddenly, the screen's
black and you're like, oh,
what's happening?
Wait, I can still hear things.
It must still be going.
Oh.
Oh, I still have to use my ears.
PABLO VILLALOBOS: And
we rationalized that
as a radar system failure.
So you're on this
spaceship, and you
have a radar of the-- your
immediate surroundings.
And then occasionally, for
whatever technical reasons,
it goes black.
And then you're flying blind.
But you can still use your
other sensors, like your ears,
to navigate.